es gibt brandheiße news zur ultima thule
denn ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt
weitere daten ausgewertet die die
raumsonde new horizons bei ihrem
vorbeiflug gesammelt hatte unter anderem
liefern hochaufgelöste bilder und
spektroskopische messungen spannende
erkenntnisse zu diesem am weitesten
entfernten und äußerst mysteriösen
himmelskörper der je von den menschen
untersucht wurde welche struktur besitzt
er in seinem außenbereich und hat der
begleiter wie monde und sogar eine
atmosphäre tricks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
unfassbare 6,5 milliarden kilometer
liegt der mysteriöse himmelskörper
ultima thule von der erde entfernt und
damit am rand unseres sonnensystems seit
dem vorbeiflug der raumsonde new
horizons anfang des jahres kommen immer
mehr erkenntnisse zur ultima thule hinzu
so auch jetzt ein forschungsteam hat
jetzt weitere daten ausgewertet denn
klar ist ultima thule ist ein besonders
spannendes forschungsobjekt denn es
stammt aus einer sehr frühen phase
unserer galaktischen heimat die chancen
sind groß dass uns neue erkenntnisse zu
diesem himmelskörper auch super
spannende erkenntnisse über die
geburtsstunde unseres sonnensystems
liefern können das team um alan stone
vom southwest research institute in
boulder hat hochaufgelöste bilder andere
daten und spektroskopische messungen
analysiert die sieben instrumente der
new horizons sonne geliefert hatten
somit steht jetzt zum einen fest dass
ultima thule wohl keine atmosphäre
besitzt die vorläufigen ergebnisse lägen
zum anderen auch nahe dass der
himmelskörper keine begleiter wie
beispielsweise monde oder aber auch
ringe hat die ergebnisse der
spektralanalyse stützen die ergebnisse
der bisherigen untersuchungen denen
zufolge die oberfläche ultima thule es
aus wassereis und methanol besteht dazu
heißt es in der neuen studie das eher
schwache signal weist aber darauf hin
dass die menge des eises zumindest in
der obersten oberflächenschicht von
61 relativ gering ist 2014 69 ist
übrigens der exakte wissenschaftliche
name des objektes der nachweis des
methanols ist laut der experten
jedenfalls auch überraschend denn bisher
konnte festes methanol nur auf wirklich
wenigen himmelskörpern im äußeren
sonnensystem nachgewiesen werden
höchstwahrscheinlich hatte sich auf
ultima thule aus wasser und einfachen
kohlenwasserstoffen gebildet auch
bezüglich seiner struktur lagen die
ersten analysen anfang des jahres gar
nicht so falsch wie schon vermutet
besitzt ultima thule eine zweigeteilte
struktur langgezogen und eher flach in
der fachsprache ist von einer bio beeren
form die rede
lobos heißt so viel wie lappen und
besteht für zwei diese quasi zweilagige
form kommt nach einschätzung des
forschungsteams wohl durch eine
kollision zwei kleinere objekte ultima
und thule die einst wohl unabhängig
voneinander entstanden sind ergaben also
ultima thule der größere teil ultima sie
tatsächlich ein wenig so aus wie ein
pfannkuchen thule der kleinere teil ist
etwas runder beide sind wohl eine
gewisse zeit um einander gekreist um
dann letztendlich sanft aneinander
anzudocken
die neuen analysen der fachleute haben
ergeben dass die koalitionsrat in der
umgebung des ungewöhnlich geformten
himmelskörpers aber eher niedrig ist
denn seine oberfläche weist nur sehr
wenige einschlagskrater auf zudem
konnten unterschiedliche geologische
strukturen ausgemacht werden messungen
legen nahe dass hellere und dunklere
flecken zu finden sind die sich wohl
sowohl in ihrer komposition als auch
farbe sehr ähnlich sind ultima thule
erscheint einheitlich rot bereits vorher
geht spektrale analysen hatten hinweise
auf organische moleküle namens doline
gegeben die sich dort möglicherweise
ansammeln der begriff doline bedeutet so
viel wie schlammig und bezeichnet lange
ketten moleküle aus kohlenstoff
stickstoff und wasserstoff
wahrscheinlich bilden sich diese doline
durch den einfluss von uv strahlung
äußerst spannende infos die also stück
für stück ein komplettes bild des
mysteriösen himmelskörpers zeichen doch
immer noch steht die forschung an
lediglich zehn prozent der informationen
die new horizon gesammelt hat konnten
bisher ausgewertet werden erst im
spätsommer 2020 werden wohl alle daten
die die sonne zur erde geschickt hat bei
uns angelangt seien kein wunder
schließlich ist ultima thule
unglaubliche 6,5 milliarden kilometer
entfernt das entspricht dem 40 fachen
abstand von der erde zur sonne doch der
ganze aufwand lohnt sich denn die
analyse von ultima thule ist für die
fachwelt eine sensation und welt
premiere noch nie hat eine sonde ein
objekt untersucht das so weit entfernt
ist hierbei kriegs und science fiction
gibt es natürlich immer direkt die
neuesten erkenntnisse
das seltsamste objekt des sonnensystems
ist noch seltsamer dann gibt's noch mehr
infos draufklicken anschauen und
natürlich klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren ist er schließlich kostenlos
bis dann bleibt dran